20e bon soir faisait 32 ans est née au
sénégal
vous habitez strasbourg où vous êtes en
doctorat de lettres modernes et vous
publié chez anne carrière un livre qui
s'appelle le ventre de l'atlantique
c'est l'histoire de saly qui comme vous
est né dans l'île de niaux d'or au
sénégal qui vit à strasbourg divorcée
d'un blanc et qui fait des études et
comme vous s'allie à un frère qui rêvent
de venir la rejoindre en france c'est un
peu la même histoire
c'est un petit peu autobiographique on
peut dire je pense alors le frère c'est
madické qui est fou de football et pour
qui la france est une espèce de d'el
dorado
il rêve en fait de venir habiter en
france
oui en fait saliver en france et puis
comme beaucoup de jeunes africains il ya
madické qui vit à new york une petite
île du sénégal et dans le village on
l'appelle maldini parce qu'ils les
foules de maldini également et il ne
rêve que d'une chose c'est rejoindre sa
soeur anne europe et devenir comme ces
stars multimillionnaire du football
évidemment c'est un vampire pour un
enfant du tiers-monde
voilà alors ils rêvent évidemment et son
rêve est entretenu par tous ceux qui
sont revenus au pays au sénégal qui ne
parlent que de richesses en oubliant les
humiliations la précarité le racisme en
fait il ya un personnage qui s'appelle
l'homme de barbès donc il habite à
barbès il a fait tous les sales boulots
tous les petits boulots ils étaient mal
payés intérimaire tout le temps sauf que
l'été y parle faire son pacha
intérimaire sous les tropiques
donc il entretient le rêve et moi je dis
c'est facile de débarquer avec une bonne
paire de nike et puis un bon team qui
vaut très cher quand on a mangé des
pâtes et puis des pommes de terre toute
l'année c'est très facile d'aller faire
fantasmer des jeunes qui n'ont jamais
rien vu d'autre que ce qu'on leur montre
à la télé parce qu'évidemment on ne leur
montre pas la vraie vie des immigrés
ainsi donc je voulais aussi analysé le
rapport difficile entre les émigrés qui
sont en france et leur famille restée au
pays
1 parce que les membres de la famille au
pays ils ne se rendent pas compte que
parfois leurs attentes sont démesurées
donc quand on est en europe et on en à
la famille a porté ce qui s'est passé
très vite et ça je sentis d'éternuements
je suis parti ici encore pire alors 11
et moi qu'est ce qui se passe comme si
un voile à vis de la poudre de
perlimpinpin j'en ai plein le pif
j'ai passé assez extraordinaire dont il
s'en fait sauvé pour sauver son frère
sally essaye de détruire le mythe de la
france eldorado et c'est ce qui est très
intéressant dans votre livre c'est à
dire c'est l'immigration les vues du
côté vu du côté africain ces revues de
là bas alors effectivement c'est vrai
que quand on quand on est un immigré
convient en france qu'on envoie des
mandats aux sénégalais qui ont fait
vivre toute une famille qui est un petit
peu une obligation vous dites d'ailleurs
on devient une espèce de héros
et quand on revient c'est ce que vous
racontez au sujet de l'homme de barbès
on peut épouser qui on veut en free
c'est vrai quoi on épouse même plus le
prétendant émigrés retour repose la
france donc quand on se marie avec la
france on peut tout espérer donc il ya
des gens qui ne savent pas qu ils
peuvent pas habiter n'importe où en
france et que ça coûterait très cher et
ça n'a rien à voir avec le niveau de vie
qu'on a au pays et donc finalement c'est
presque plus facile de les aider à
réussir sur place qu de les amener ici
gerrit part d'autobiographie
ben moi je dis toujours pour m'amuser on
va dire 80 % ça ne peut pas se mesurer
aux mains nues la mode c'est bien parti
donc je dis ça parce que je pense que le
premier sacrifice de les clients comme
disait quelqu'un s'est lui-même
donc je parle de mes expériences et
aussi d'une révolte intérieure je pense
que ce ne sont pas des lois qui vont
changer l'immigration c'est une
nécessité de francis des immigrés
eux-mêmes
moi ça ne me gênait pas de dire que je
faisais femme de ménage en alsace pour
payer mes études à partir du moment où
on dit ça c'est vrai qu'on perd en
luminosité
on n'est plus aussi enviée on n'est plus
aussi admirer ou n'est plus adulées du
temps mais en revanche on expose la
vérité telle qu'elle est oui alors
l'homme de barbès lui effectivement
quand ils arrivent au sénégal même quels
que soient les boulots qu'il ait pu
faire en france il dit mais la france un
pays formidable n'y a pas de pauvres en
france il dit par exemple bien que tout
le monde a le rmi donc il dit tu passes
ta journée à baillet devant la télé et
on te file le revenu
simone d'un ingénieur chez nous il est
donc convenu maximum de l'ingénieur
chine 1
voilà donc voilà il parle des
allocations familiales aussi dit chaque
nuit d'amour est un investissement
évidemment parce que plus on a des
enfants
plus on gagne de pognon il dit il suffit
de faire des enfants pour être payé à
rien faire voilà c'est quand même ce qui
va mal et qui ramasse les crottes de
chien à paris sont payés par la mairie
seront payés par une quand on sait qu'on
peut être là bas et travailler dur dans
les champs et nous rien gagné à la fin
du mois et imaginez ramasser quelques
crottes de chien à paris pour être riche
évidemment ça fait ça prend des
proportions ça prend des proportions
mythique est en fait en réalité vous dit
cet homme de barbaise qui friment comme
ça quand ils retournent au sénégal il a
dormi dans des bouches de métro il a il
a chapardé pour manger il a survécu
grâce à l'armée du salut et puis là il a
il a tenu un marteau piqueur sans
territoire ils avaient attaqué le
marteau piqueur pour par toutes les
saisons donc il a dû tout supporter sauf
qu'une fois au pays
l'image dorée son respect fait qu' il
n'a pas envie de révéler la vérité et
moi je pense que ce n'est pas seulement
une analyse de l'immigré c'est tout
simplement la vanité humaine
donc personne n'a envie de dire ce qu'il
a enduré sur son passage pour venir pour
être au sommet donc c'est à nous les
immigrés de dire à nos frères ce qu'on a
fait avant parce que ce qui est très
touchant dans votre bouquin c'est qu'en
fait il a fait tout un tas de métiers
terrible il a une vie terrible cet homme
de barbès et à un moment il a vraiment
réussi quand il est devenu on peut dire
un cap au cirque anti la coque quand il
devenu le contrôleur de ses semblables
oui parce qu'il est vigile donc je dis
il est passé de maîtres chiens du maître
l'a donc quand il voit ses semblables
ses frères d'itinéraires où ils sont
trop arrogant pour faire leurs courses
dans les supermarchés donc ils les
trouvent trop arrogant pour faire leurs
courses comme les blancs ou alors ils
les trouvent trop pauvre pour être
honnête donc de toutes les manières
cartonné type et on est louche a priori
mais oui et c'est à cause de ça que je
dis aussi c
c'est semblable qui l'arrêté ils ont
fini par comprendre conseiller en exil
le plus terrible pour l'étranger en
france ce n'est pas seulement
l'autochtone raciste c'est aussi notre
qui a envie de changer de camp et qui se
donne tous les moyens pour ça et qui
finit par oublier d'où il vient assez
extraordinaires sont donc ces dunes
c'est d'une précision chirurgicale sur
l'immigration c'est très très fort
vraiment alors au chapitre des
humiliations vous raconter l'arrivée de
salies mais on peut penser effectivement
que c'est vous à 80% en france elle est
autorisée à rester au départ parce
qu'elle n'est pas malade qu'elle passe
un examen de santé qui du coup de quand
même une certaine somme 320 francs et
elle est autorisée à rester parce
qu'elle est pas malade et c'est
exactement ce qui se passait du temps
des esclaves voulzy très bien c'est à
dire que à l'époque de du trafic
d'esclaves on ceux qui étaient malades
dont les éliminés ont gardé que ce
qu'était le tessin est bien portant et
la france se comporte aujourd'hui nous
savons tout à fait légalement comme un
négrier jeudi à l'époque où on vendait
pêle-mêle le nez dans les bennes et les
épices personne n'achetait d'esclaves
malades
donc maintenant il faut savoir que la
maladie c'est une tare rédhibitoire pour
l'accès au territoire français il faut
passer une radio intégral moi quand je
suis arrivé j'ai dû passer cette radio
intégral et j'étais très pudique est la
dame disait mais si vous voulez rétablir
vous n'aviez qu'à rester chez vous donc
je ne suis pas venu en france non plus
pour être à poil 1
enfin pas tout le temps disons celle de
mal vrai nom ça dépend avec qui
alors vous c'est là je parle plus de
l'héroïne du bouquin salim et je parle
de vous faites tout vous est pas venu en
france pour faire fortis détenus en
france parce que sénégal vous aviez
rencontré un jeune coopérant dont vous
êtes tombée amoureuse vous dites là
quand un mec vous regarde dans les yeux
en me disant je t'aime un peu naïf c'est
tout sur les 20 cl difficile de résister
et alors vous avez épousé ce français et
vous une erreur de casting en fait une
erreur de casting
les couples mixtes ne marche pas vous
dit non ils peuvent marcher mais ça
dépend avec qui il faut il faut être
assez construit pour ça moi je trouve
qu'un comprimé que c'est un idéal
d'ouverture tout simplement ça
correspond à ce que j'ai dans la tête et
je peux le vivre ça ne me pose pas de
problème parce que j'en arrive à oublier
la couleur de l'autre c'est dans le
regard des personnes qu'on rencontrait
que je me rendais compte en fait qu'on
était différent et en fait c'est une
erreur de casting parce que quand je
suis arrivé les siens attendait blanche
neige vous a été complètement rejeté par
la famille et vous dites c'est pas une
histoire de culture parce qu'on dit
souvent c'est une histoire de culture
mais vous la culture occidentale vous la
posséder parfaitement fait des études de
lettres modernes
enfin bon vous êtes quelqu'un de très
attentif à la culture occidentale
on peut même pas dire que c'est ce à
quoi ça marche pas parce que ça ne peut
pas marcher racisme j'ai souvent entendu
dire que les parents se dit fallait les
vents se disent oh là là nos petits
enfants vont être métisse qua non pas de
[ __ ] dans la famille c'est là
qu'est ce que j'entendais
quotidiennement classe alors que vous je
disais les dépliants gosse je disais que
j'étais intéressé par la culture
occidentale
à peine arrivée vous avez sur la tombe
de chateaubriand à saint malo à peine
arrivé en france alors qu'il y est
écrivain mais pour vous c'est
inimaginable devenir écrivain c'est
quelque chose de participer vraiment là
du mythe c'est le cas de le dire du rêve
est alors votre mari français alsacien
voulez pas vous écriviez
sa famille non plus il voulait même pas
que je devienne prof de français ce qui
vous attend ma naturalisation par
mariage est sorti il a refusé de la
signer
donc on a fini par me l'a refusé j'ai dû
me battre après des années tout seul
parce qu'il ne voulait pas que je puisse
passer le concours du capes pour
enseigner le français
donc j'ai continué et puis chaque année
je demander la nationalité on me la
refuse et je faisais un autre diplôme on
me refusait encore la nationalité je
faisais un autre diplôme
donc j'ai atterri un doctorat par hasard
mais c'était martin luther queen
exactement est ce que c'est vrai que lui
n'est plus tellement pas que vous
écriviez qu'il est parti un jour avec
votre manuscrit le premier est un jeu
quand on a réclamé ça parce qu'il ya eu
un procès et où il a jamais voulu le
rendre
il dit qu'il a détruit qu'il a aussi
détruit les disquettes puisqu'il avait
aussi abîmé l'ordinateur il fallait pas
que j'écrive vous pensez une négresse en
plus intello qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire
donc il est parti avec quand j réclamé
au jeune avocate qui s'est battu elle
n'a rien pu récupérer puis moi je leur
ai dit laisser tomber quoi il a tout
emporté sauf nos cerveaux dans la rue
pour continuer vous êtes en proie au
racisme dont on est des phrases du genre
une femme chez qui vous allez chercher
du boulot un moment qui vous dis toi
y'en à comprendre madame je veux dire
que en 2000 quelques il ya encore des
gens qui vous parle comme ça alors moi
je dis qu'il ya peut-être des
occidentaux qui aurait des leçons à
tirer de quelques fois de rigueur du
tiers-monde
comment je viens de matières molles mais
j'avais déjà vu beaucoup de pays
européens parce que quand je faisais des
ménages m'offrait des voyages jusqu'aux
états unis
c'était pour m'ouvrir la tête donc quand
vous tombez sur une dame qui n'a vu que
sa campagne natale
il a beau être naturalisé français avoir
toute la culture de faim de base de
victor hugo il n'a rien de plus qu'un
digne sédentaires beugnot
mouais
mais la libye réuni levin pas rentrer
dans la forêt on fait des trucs en
imaginant des bandes dessinées comme
qu'on peut pas imaginer qu'en dix jours
du grand soir
et là vous êtes formidables faut dire
les choses comme la vous avez beaucoup
de brou d'intelligence évidemment c'est
que vous dites que vous êtes la pitié
pour ces gens-là et qu'en fait vous êtes
plus choqué par le racisme sournois des
gens qui disent j'aime pas les étrangers
mais toi je t'aime bien parce que tu
étais en toile a donc celles au racisme
pour moi le plus terrible parce que
quand quelqu'un de ceux de cultiver vous
dit ça il a l'impression de vous élire
son estime
c'est justement le moment où moi je le
déteste parce qu'en fait quand il dit
j'aime pas les étrangers mais toi tu es
différentes moi je voudrais qu'ils se
demandent ce que les étrangers pensent
de quelqu'un d'aussi belles conduit 1
c'est ça arrive c'est très sain alors on
va terminer sur une phrase de vous que
dans votre livre que j'aime beaucoup
pour finir vous dit partir c'est devenir
un tombeau en bus oui mais vous vivez
comme ça avec votre théâtre d'ombrés
dans la tête quoi c'est de venir d'un
tombeau ambulant où les vivants et les
morts en l'absence en partage parce
qu'on porte en nous nos familles qu'on a
laissé derrière nous en portons en nous
aussi nos morts nos souvenirs d'enfance
et tout ça est en nous mais personne ne
peut le voir et moi travers ce livre je
voulais aussi raconter le destin
il ya des personnages qui traînent leur
destin et je voulais pas receler vous
dire aussi aux occidentaux
quand vous regardez un étranger regarder
l'histoire humaine qui a derrière tout
le monde n'est pas venu voler une tarte
à la crème qu'est-ce que viser volcan
ici
a aiguisé que font les américains
arrivent en irak ils se rendent pas
compte que des gens qui sont en train de
bombarder ont cinq mille ans d'histoire
derrière c'est exactement ça et je dis
parfois on dort tranquille parce que les
cris des autres n'arrivent pas jusqu'à
nos oreilles
merci ça fait du bien
à
dieu mais ça ça mène le ventre de
l'atlantique c'est publié chez anne
carrière
c'est magnifique merci des corrections
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus